well I know you said that you appreciate
USC and I get it because the people in
the documentary they also said that
their school they still have nothing but
respect for but it was a very
excruciating process and one of the
teachers even said well if you think
this is difficult try being out in the
real world so it was like this sort of
like breeding ground like okay who's
gonna make it who's not and some people
didn't make it and I was wondering how
that was for you because it sounds like
you have a very supportive family and
you came from a supportive college where
you had your four-year degree yeah what
advice would you give to someone that's
coming here that they know that this is
just part of what they have to go
through it's not intentional they're not
trying to be mean but right yeah yeah my
advice I think would just be did not
quit because it's super easy to get
discouraged and to feel bitter and to
feel like all these people don't get me
they don't you know and stuff like that
but the the great part is that like it
does it does force you to examine what
you're doing to examine your intention
and your work and to sharpen it so it's
the clearest most precise version of
what you're trying to do and and when
you when you realize like when you when
you take your ego out of the process and
you and you go into a note session
thinking like okay I'm just here to get
information that information is so I can
improve my work it's not not going there
to get validation that you're that
you're good at what you do it's it's not
that's not what that process is for this
is like a process of like whittling you
know whittling a stick into something
sharp you know and then when you're done
with that whittling process then you can
you can sort of release it into the
world and have it be something that
you're proud of hopefully and and that
process is so critical because I when I
think about how I used to work as an
artist but as a creator before my film
school experience I would just like you
know if I was gonna make a short which I
made a short before I went to school and
I made one cut and that was it
I was like oh cool I'm done like I
because it's right there I did it you
know but then you realized that like in
film school that's where you begin
that's where the work starts is on your
first try on your first try where you
thought you you crushed it and you
realize oh I actually didn't crush it at
all and that that sense of kind of
humility that comes with the craft is
like a really beautiful place to be in
at least I I feel that way and just I I
now love that process and but it's
unfortunate I actually sauce on my
friends didn't make it through the
program like because like they they were
getting so much harsh feedback I think
they thought they started to take it
personally and I started to think like
well nobody gets what I'm doing and so
they dropped out of the program and
that's really unfortunate I mean like
I'm not saying that that's staying and
everybody has their own path so maybe
that was best for them but when I wanted
to quit I'm really really really
grateful that I didn't because it would
have if I would have quit like right
after that note session where I write
wept bitterly I would have relieved
myself of some short-term pain but I I
wouldn't be nearly the filmmaker than I
am right now and and the great part also
about the notes process is it it sort of
it keeps you humble in the sense that
you realize that that there's so much
that you don't know and there's so much
to be explored that like the the journey
of becoming quote a good filmmaker or a
good writer is a lifelong process and
wherever we are in the process that's
just where you are and I'm grateful that
like I feel like I'm I'm like just now
to the point where I'm like okay I'm
gonna try something new and I might fail
but I've I've gotten through failure
before and I'm still here so I know that
I can get through it
you